Isang larangan kung saan maaaring mapabuti ng quantum computing ang machine learning
ay ang may kaugnayan sa kernel functions o
kernel matrices — tuklasin natin kung ano ang mga ito
at bakit kailangan natin ang mga ito. Para dito, aalalahanin natin ang
tatlong bagay: bakit lumalabas ang dot products sa machine learning,
bakit kinasasangkutan ng mas mataas na dimensyon ang mga problema sa machine learning,
at ano ang kernel functions
Alalahanin na ang dot product o inner product ng
n-dimensional na real vectors na a
at b ay ibinibigay ng produkto ng magnitude ng a,
ang magnitude ng b, at ang cosine ng theta — ang anggulo
sa pagitan nila. Katumbas ito ng pagmumultiply
ng bawat component ng a sa katumbas na component ng
b at pagsasama-sama. Pansinin na kung ang mga vector ay
halos orthogonal — halimbawa kapag ang a
ay may zero na components kung saan malaki ang mga component ng b —
maliit ang dot product. Katumbas ito ng
theta na malapit sa pi over two.
Gayundin, kung ang a ay may negatibong components habang ang b
ay may positibong components,
ibig sabihin ang mga vector ay nakatutok sa
halos kabaligtarang direksyon,
at ang theta ay malapit sa pi,
ang resulta ng dot product ay maaaring
negatibo. At panghuli, kung ang a ay may malalaking component kung saan ang b
ay mayroon ding malalaking component na parehong sign,
kung kaya't halos parallel ang mga vector at ang theta ay malapit sa zero,
malaki ang magiging dot product
at positibo. Kaya naman, makatwirang asahan na ang dot products
ay magiging kapaki-pakinabang na sukatan ng pagkakatulad
sa mga data point. Hindi lahat ng n-dimensional na data
ay madaling mahihiwalay gamit ang n minus
one dimensional na hiwa — ibig sabihin, isang linya,
eroplano, o hyperplane. Kapag hindi magandang nahihiwalay ang data
sa n na dimensyon, maaari nating i-embed ang mga data point
sa mas mataas na dimensyon — sabihin nating m dimensions, kung saan ang m
ay mas malaki sa n. Tinatawag itong feature mapping,
kadalasang tinutukoy bilang x na napupunta sa phi(x), kung saan
ang phi(x) ay isang mapping mula sa n-dimensional na real numbers patungo sa
m-dimensional na real numbers.
Pinakamadaling isipin ito kapag
binibingkis ang isang set ng one-dimensional na data pataas sa
dalawang dimensyon, o kinukuha ang two-dimensional na data
at ine-embed ito sa tatlong dimensyon.
Pero sa katotohanan, kadalasan nating ine-embed ang data sa mga espasyo na may libu-libo
o maging milyun-milyong dimensyon.
Ang dot product ng three-dimensional vectors kumpara sa dot product
ng two-dimensional vectors ay hindi gaanong malaking pagkakaiba.
Pero ang dot product ng isang milyong dimensional na vectors
ay nagiging ganap na hindi magagawa
sa isang malaking dataset.
Kaya naman, nag-isip ng matalinong paraan ang mga tao.
Paano kung gumamit ka ng projection
sa mas mataas na dimensyon na may napaka-tiyak na anyo,
kung kaya't ang dot products ng mga vector sa
mas mataas na dimensyon ay isang simpleng function ng
mas mababang dimensional na vectors? Ibig sabihin, mahanap tayo ng mapping
mula sa ating data x patungo sa mas mataas na dimensional na phi(x),
kung kaya't ang inner product sa
feature space ay ibinibigay ng isang
simpleng function sa mas mababang dimensional na data.
Ang function na ito, k, ay tinatawag na kernel function.
Idealmente, gusto nating ang kernel function na ito
ay maging function ng mas mababang dimensional na
inner product mismo — bibigyan tayo nito ng
pinakamabuting resulta: napakataas na dimensional na feature space
ngunit may mura at madaling kalkulahing inner product.
Sa unang tingin, hindi
agad halata na posible ito. Tingnan natin ang
isang simpleng halimbawa sa napakababang dimensyon.
Isaalang-alang ang tiyak na feature mapping na ito: nagma-map ito ng
three-dimensional na vector papunta sa
nine-dimensional na espasyo. Lumalabas na
ang inner product ng nine-dimensional na feature-mapped
espasyo ay simpleng ibinibigay ng inner product sa orihinal na
three-dimensional na espasyo, nakwadrado. Kaya ang inner product
ng mapped na espasyo gamit ang phi functions
ay mangangailangan ng pagkalkula ng bawat isa sa
siyam na coordinates para sa
unang vector at siyam para sa
pangalawa, pagkatapos ay ang inner product mismo, na
siyam pang produkto at pagsasama —
kabuuang dalawampu't walong operasyon.
Ang kernel function ay nangangailangan ng tatlong produkto
at dalawang pagsasama — katumbas lang ng apat na operasyon.
Iyon ay para sa pag-map ng three-dimensional na data point patungo sa
nine-dimensional na feature space.
Madaling makita kung gaano ito kapaki-pakinabang
para sa napakalalaking espasyo.
Ang kernel function ay karaniwang isang tuluy-tuloy na function
na maaaring ilapat sa anumang vector sa iyong dataset.
Ginagamit natin ang kernel functions sa pamamagitan ng pagkuha ng
mga pares ng data point mula sa ating set
bilang mga argumento. Ang paglalapat ng kernel function sa
bawat pares ng data point sa set
ay nagbubunga ng isang symmetric matrix na tinatawag na kernel
matrix. Ang uri ng kernel function na gagamitin mo ay depende sa
iyong problema. Kaya para buod:
ang paglalarawan ng pagkakatulad ng mga vector sa ating dataset
ay kadalasang nangangailangan ng inner products. Ang inner products sa
napakataas na dimensional na feature space ay nagiging mahal.
Kaya gumagamit tayo ng feature mappings na katumbas
ng ilang espesyal na kernel functions
na nagpapabilis ng kalkulasyon.
Ngunit ang limitasyon sa mga espesyal na kernel function na ito
ay nagbabawal sa ilang uri ng mappings patungo sa feature space na
maaaring gawin nang mahusay. Ito
ay maaaring mahadlangan tayo sa magandang paghihiwalay ng ating data.
Kung mayroon lang ibang paraan.
Dito pumapasok ang quantum computing.
Ang napakataas na dimensional na feature mapping na katumbas
ng kernel functions ay maaaring isagawa
sa isang quantum computer gamit ang quantum kernel estimator.
Doon, kinakalkula ang kernel matrix k,
at mula roon, maaaring gamitin ang klasikal na machine learning algorithm para
maisakatuparan ito. Ang isang data point x1
ay ino-load at mina-map, pagkatapos
ay ino-load ang isa pang x2
at mina-map. Dahil ang inner product ng dalawang quantum states
ay may kaugnayan sa measurement probability,
maaari nating tantiyahin ang inner product ng dalawang mapped na
data point sa pamamagitan ng sapat na maraming measurements ng
resultang circuit. Sa ganitong paraan, ang ating circuit
ay makapagbibigay ng impormasyon tungkol sa inner product
sa anumang mataas na dimensional na espasyo na kayang i-model ng circuit —
nang hindi klasikal na kinakalkula ang inner product o
kernel function. Maraming paraan ng
pag-customize at pagpapahusay sa mga pamamaraang ito,
at palagi na ngayong may mga bagong pamamaraan na iminumungkahi
at sinusubukan. Umaasa kami na ang
pangkalahatang-ideyang ito ay nakatulong sa pag-frame ng
paggamit ng quantum computing
sa mga pamamaraan ng machine learning,
lalo na ang mga kinasasangkutan ng kernels.